bonjour à tous à suivre dans un instant
l'audition d'henri proglio le pdg d'edf
qui a été auditionné par le sénat la
semaine dernière quelques jours après la
présentation en conseil des ministres
des grandes lignes du projet de loi sur
la transition énergétique par ségolène
royal alors henri proglio a été
auditionnée elle la semaine dernière par
les commissions du développement durable
et des affaires économiques sur deux
éléments notamment est il possible de
porter à l'horizon 2030 à 40 % de la
part des énergies notre part d'énergie
renouvelable deuxième autre question qui
a été posée à henri proglio
quel sera l'impact pour edf d'un point
de vue économique de faire porter à la
moitié de la production d'énergie la
part du nucléaire tout de suite donc
retour à cette audition qui s'est
déroulée mardi dernier au sénat c'est un
c'est un honneur d'être d'être présent
aujourd'hui devant vous j'avais préparé
le texte je vous laisserai d'ailleurs
mais je vais m'en d'évadés tout de suite
pour répondre le plus possible
directement aux sujets qui sont évoqués
par le président et pour cadrer un peu
le sujet
il faut qu est ce qu on appelle
transition énergétique elle est
l'ambition de la france qu'elles sont
des des caractéristiques de la france
dans le monde quels sont les besoins
énergétiques
et quel meilleur mix énergétique non
seulement en termes de production dans
le terme d' approche dumas général
de bourges où
vous allez demander quelques quelques
éléments sur edf en soit la société edf
qui est maintenant une société cotée en
bourse dont g
l'honneur d'être le responsable c'est
une entreprise
société anonyme donc cotées sur le
marché de paris
au cac 40
dans la capitalisation boursière avant
les événements de la semaine dernière
était de l'ordre de 53 54 milliards
d'euros et ont peu fondu
des raisons l'exotique c'est une
entreprise qui fait à peu près 80
milliards de chiffre d'affaires je pars
la neuro bien entendu dont deux tiers en
france un tiers à l'international qui
vocation évidemment à voir ce la partie
internationale se renforcer qui compte
de l'ordre de 165 mille collaborateurs
avant la prise en compte de
l'intégration de dalkia qui doit se
produire en des premiers durant la
première quinzaine du mois de juillet si
bruxelles selon toute attente donne son
feu vert dalkia ses 15000 personnes
et ses dehors du milliard de chiffre
d'affaires fin voilà donc on sera au
dessus de 85 me garer avec
175 mid collaborateurs
c'est une entreprise c'est le premier
électricien du monde c'est le premier
opérateur
nucléaire monde c'est le premier
opérateur hydraulicien en europe
c'est le premier opérateur de réseaux en
europe et l'un des plus grands au monde
c'est le premier centre de recherche
mondial en matière d'électricité
c'est la référence mondiale en matière
de systèmes électriques waskie df au
fond c'est le premier investisseur
européen ce que beaucoup de gens
ignorent nous avons un plan
d'investissements si dieu le permet
c'est à dire si on des personnes pas par
des mesures
qui nous interdirait de faire face à ses
engagements nous avons un plan
d'investissements de l'ordre de 200
milliards d'euros dans les dix ans qui
viennent dont 120 milliards à peu près
en france et 80 milliards à
l'international dont laurent britannique
du nucléaire
particulièrement nos grosses positions à
l'international sont évidemment la
grande bretagne italie l'europe centrale
y compris la belgique et la pologne
sommes le premier opérateur français
premier opérateur britannique deuxième
opérateur italien troisième opérateur
polonais deuxième opérateur belge
nous sommes depuis 30 ans en chine ceux
qui nous connaissent le savent nous
avons exporté là bas notre compétence
dans le domaine du nucléaire nous sommes
dans l'hydraulique au laos nous sommes
en amérique latine notamment au brésil
il fait aujourd'hui parler de lui nous
sa mort en amérique du nord nous sommes
au moyen-orient et nous avons des
ambitions partout voilà ce qu'est edf en
quelques mots
l'énergie
il y à des phases de l'histoire du monde
alors d'abord le monde le monde ces sept
milliards d'habitants aujourd'hui
c'était un milliard et demi au début du
20e siècle on perd souvent
je dirais la mémoire de ce qu'est
d'évolution du monde monde à quintupler
sa population malgré les deux grandes
guerres mondiales du 20e siècle en
l'espace d'un siècle ça sera neuf
milliards d'habitants d'ici 2030
on voit ce que ça implique comme
conséquences en matière de besoins
primaires en eau en énergie en
nourriture en santé besoins fondamentaux
et quand on regarde la france vue du
vaste monde on n'a pas le sentiment
connaît dans cet univers la référence
dans ces domaines d'activité extrêmement
précis et extrêmement précieux ne le
perdons pas de vue tout le monde un
regard particulier vers le système
français en matière d'énergie parce que
la france a su anticiper c'est un des
domaines dans lesquels la france dispose
d'atouts absolument unique
parce qu'au début des années soixante
dix en constatant que au fond les chocs
pétroliers allaient se multiplier la
france a pris l'initiative de se doter
dans le domaine de l'électricité d'un
outil unique au monde qui est sa
plateforme nucléaire qui avait vocation
à donner à la france à la fois son
indépendance dans le domaine de
l'énergie électrique et la compétitivité
du territoire et de fait
quelques 35 ans plus tard on constate
que la france est le seul exportateur le
premier exportateur d'électricité en
europe et c'est le pays dont le coût de
l'électricité le coût de revient est le
plus faible en europe
dont nous sommes totalement indépendants
dans ce domaine et nous avons une
capacité d'exportation
est un atout de compétitivité
article article 2 on re découvre ce
qu'est d'énergie aujourd'hui dont lors
de la campagne électorale pour le medef
j'avais eu la visite des candidats
les uns et les autres me rappelait que
l'énergie non
c'était pour l'entreprise france c'est à
dire tous les secteurs d'activité
confondus en matière d'industrie pour
l'industrie française le
le coût du travail représente 40% de la
moyenne des coûts de la production
industrielle française le coût de
l'énergie 20% quand on sait les
difficultés les drames que représente le
gain d'1 % sur le coût du travail on
voit l'importance qu'il ya à ne pas
oublier l'importance de la compétitivité
liée au coût de l'énergie les américains
sont là pour le prouver car avec les gaz
de schiste et la révolution
technologique que représente les gaz de
schiste asie sa vie dont le coût du vous
le savez en tout cas historiquement du
coût du gaz aux etats-unis a été divisé
par quatre au cours des dix dernières
années et on voit les évolutions
considérables que cela implique et en
matière de réindustrialisation du
territoire nord-américain de la création
d'emplois l'essentiel du rebond
industriel américain provenant du coût
de l'énergie
voilà les attendus du sujet enfin notons
qu'en france si on regarde les chiffres
98% des 70 milliards de déficit du
commerce extérieur français sont tout
simplement lié à l'importation d'énergie
fossile gaz et pétrole
c'est à dire que si on faisait
l'économie des importations d'énergie
fossile il n'y aura plus de déficit du
corps et ses soeurs français et ce
déficit se creuse d'aniane
voilà les enjeux
compétitivité pouvoir d'achat
d'industrialisation emploi
investissement
alors
parlons de transition énergétique
le sujet de la france quality 1 comment
économiser l'énergie de manière importé
moins subir moins de déficit du relais
cci ailleurs tout en gardant la
compétitivité du théâtre l'article
l'article 2 cali le mix énergétique
susceptibles de répondre le mieux à
cette attente
donc
dans les attendus d'une réflexion
stratégie sur l'optimisation énergétique
sûr est ce qu'on peut appeler la
transition énergétique je voudrais qu'on
oublie simplement le terme transition et
électriques une pourcentage d électro
nucléaire dans la production
d'électricité une regardons la
transition énergétique
avec
comme priorité la première des priorités
c'est les économies d'énergie comment
faire en sorte que le pays économisent
l'énergie qu'elle consomme qu'ils
consomment de manière efficiente et
efficace quelles sont les mesures à
prendre en matière d'économie d'énergie
qui a la foi relève du bon sens qui
relève de l'efficacité économique et pas
uniquement des subventions comment faire
en sorte que le pays s'engage dans la
voie d'une optimisation énergétique au
sens des économies d'énergie efficace ça
c'est la première des priorités la
deuxième c'est quels sont les besoins en
énergie du pays à l'horizon des années
2030 2040 bon en se projetant dans cet
univers-là en tenant compte de
l'évolution de la france dans la période
intermédiaire entre 2012 date à laquelle
on a lancé ce mot d'ordre de transition
énergétique et des années 2030 2040 les
3e en cadets et meilleur remix à ce
moment-là adapté pour permettre
une efficacité des mesures qui sont
adaptés ils sont entreprises
il faut prêt à faire des hypothèses dans
cet immeuble dont la france de 2010 25
2030-2035 ne ressemblera pas la faute ne
sera pas tout à fait la même elle sera
pas figé dans le marbre ce ne sera pas
la france de 2012 d'abord parce que la
france a une des caractéristique unique
en son genre en europe c'est que d'un
thème pays dont la démographie est
positif
seul pays européen dans la démographie
significativement positive heures de 2%
par an ce qui est exactement inverse de
l'allemagne l'italie et quand on fait
des comparaisons on oublie toujours ça
plane man se dépeuple l'italie se
dépeuple à france ce peuple 2% par an ça
veut dire que d'ici 2025 par exemple il
y aura six millions d'habitants de plus
en france quel besoin de la faim ne
seront pas les mêmes qu'en 2012
deuxièmement
la croissance économique car aujourd'hui
en france vous avez 70 % de la
consommation d'électricité et je pense
d'énergie au sens large il faudra le
vérifier qu'ils sont liés
aux particuliers
et 30% fin deux tiers-un tiers à peu
près liés à l'entreprise et à l'économie
à l'industrie
évidemment les besoins de l'industrie
sont directement corrélée à la
croissance du secteur industriel et donc
si on veut regarder les besoins de la
france en les anticipant là les
accompagnant il faut avoir une idée de
ce que va être le développement et la
croissance économique de ce pays dans
les 20 à 30 ans qui viennent
il m'est arrivé d'imaginer ne dirais pas
de rêver mais d'imaginer que la france
comme d'autres d'ailleurs pourrait avoir
un taux de croissance de l'ordre de 2 2%
par an à effet composer ce qui est
nécessaire pour maintenir l'emploi dans
ce pays
d'autant que la croissance démographique
est là pour renforcer ce besoin et bien
si on se projette à cet horizon-là alors
vous voyez que les besoins en énergie de
la france compte tenu des économies
d'énergie dont on peut imaginer qu'elle
représente 20 % d'économies sur
l'ensemble des énergies à l'horizon des
2000 2025-2030 que malgré tout les
besoins en énergie du pays compte tenu
de la croissance démographique il va
croissante économique resteront positifs
ça c'est le besoin en énergie ensuite
quels sont les énergies les plus
efficaces je constate que dans la en
france nous important toutes nos
énergies primaires à l'exception d'une
d'électricité
toutes les énergies fossiles sont
apportées donc on n'a aucun avantage
compétitif dans ces domaines tout est
importé n'avons pas de ressources
prendre
seul d'électricité n'est pas importée
mais est fabriqué et même nous donne un
petit bonus à l'exportation donc si je
devais donner une priorité aux mix
énergétique français je pense qu'on
aurait tout intérêt à pousser la
consommation d'une énergie qui est la
plus compétitive parce qu'elle se
détache clairement par rapport à la
moyenne européenne 1 et kristen et 40%
moins chère que la moyenne européenne
plutôt que dans les énergies fossiles
dont on peut dire que ça ne donne aucun
avantage compétitif puisque nous les
importants en totalité ce qui n'est pas
le cas par exemple de la norvège ou de
la grande bretagne jusqu'à date
prochaine puisque les ressources en
train de s'épuiser et puis par ailleurs
elles sont en écosse qui fait l'objet
d'un référendum que vous voulez
peut-être mensuellement
donc
si d'aventuré on me poser à la caisse de
la question au citoyen que je suis
président d'edf de savoir quelle énergie
il faut favoriser en france je dirais
bon d'abord il faut regarder les besoins
en énergie au sens large et à
l'intérieur des énergies l'énergie la
plus propre celle qui est la plus
efficace qu'à la plus compétitive celle
qui est la plus
directe qui donne le l'indépendance
énergétique puisqu'on a produit une once
et l'électricité si j'ajoute à ça
que l'évolution naturelle
des besoins des particuliers des
entreprises c'est-à-dire toutes les
nouvelles technologies une nouvelle
application l'abonné rni telle
efficacité
tous les éléments concourent à faire en
sorte que dans le portefeuille dans le
portefeuille énergétique de chacun
d'entre vous la part de l'électricité
augmentent en valeur relative d'année en
année plus
de temps passe plus l'électricité
dominent le paysage de du mix
énergétique individuelle des foyers
français par définition puisque toutes
les nouvelles applications encore une
fois est aujourd'hui encore plus à
travers la mobilité l'électricité domine
paysage donc et pour faire simple dans
nos calculs dans les calculs que la
nation devrait faire il ya d'abord un
priorité des économies d'énergie ensuite
l'optimisation du mix énergétique et
enfin à l'intérieur du système
électrique quelles sont
les origines de l'électricité qui sont
les plus efficaces
ma conviction celle qui ressort de nos
calculs nous sommes là pour vous donner
toutes les ai tous les éléments
d'information sont que les projections
en matière de besoins en énergie de la
part d'électricité dans l'énergie font
que
à l'horizon 2028 2030 des besoins en
électricité de la france sans qu'il y
ait un changement considérable dans la
répartition des énergies mais accompagné
en l'évolution vers l'électricité du 8e
agetic global
les besoins en électricité de la france
seront tels que le parc nucléaire
existant
y compris le réacteur de flamanville
suffiront à peine à représenter 50% des
besoins en électricité de la france si
les deux pour cent lui 2 2 entre 2 et 2
1% de croissance en valeur en intérêts
composés sont son
sont au rendez-vous et si on prend en
compte l'évolution démographique et
malgré les 20% d'économies d'énergie
voilà
le credo sur lequel évidemment je ne
demande à personne de nous rejoindre les
yeux fermés mais en tout cas qui
justifie qu'on se pose au moins la
question
parc existant
donc c'est à dire la capacité
les 58 réacteurs français existants plus
nouveaux acteurs de l'affairé
deuxièmement
le coût des énergies
quel est le coût de production de
l'électricité provenant des origines
diverses
aujourd'hui on peut dire
que le si on met de côté aujourd'hui la
france dispose de 75 % de ces deux de
ses produits de sa production électrique
à partir de l'électronucléaire 12% à peu
près 12 et demi pour se répartir de
l'hydraulique et le reste sous forme
soit d'énergies nouvelles soit 2
de fioul ou de gaz nadir de thermique
classique en pointe particulièrement
le coût de production du mégawatt elle
est électrique
pour l'hydraulique c'est difficile parce
qu'il faudrait tenir compte de
l'investissement nécessaire pour les
porcs en barrage et vont virtuelle des
barrages et temps très anciens ils sont
déjà complètement amortis donc le plus
compétitif et évidemment ils
l'hydroélectricité j'y reviendrai un
instant puisque président m'a demandé
d'y revenir sur le sujet de la mise en
concurrence des barrages car les
barrages sont les seuls éléments stables
fiables et compétitives de stockage de
l'énergie aujourd'hui avec les ballons
d'eau chaude
puisque le stockage de l'énergie est un
sujet sur lequel on travaille énormément
on cherche beaucoup on n'a pas encore
trouvé
melo
c'est le meilleur stockage existants de
l'énergie donc les barrages
l'énergie thermique d'origine
pétrole charbon gaz a un coût qui est
compris entre 75
et 80 85 euros le mégawattheure
l'énergie
électro-nucléaire provenant du parc
nucléaire existant et la cour des
comptes l'a validé à deux reprises par
les deux analyses qui ont été faites ces
55 euros le mégawattheure
les énergies nouvelles
l'éolien en fonction alors sans tenir
compte du coût de l'intermittence qui
devrait se rajouter
au coût des énergies nouvelles l'éolien
onshore nous l'ordre de
90 à 110 mégawatts heure l'éolien
offshore de l'ordre de 150 à 200
le photovoltaïque de l'ordre de 180 250
voilà les prix de revient bon pour les
énergies nouvelles ne tenant pas compte
encore une fois de l'intermittence c'est
à dire des coûts de structure lié au
réseau d'une part est liée à la
doucement nécessaire des moyens
classiques thermiques pour faire face
ou à la ligue en maintenant dans le mix
énergétique de demain
force est de constater que le coût moyen
d énergie produite certains rapports
avec le coût de revient final de
l'énergie distribuée et que par
conséquent ou bien les subventionnent et
dans ce cas-là ça sort de la poche du
contribuable plutôt que du contenu du
consommateur ou bien fait payer le coût
de l'énergie effectivement consommateurs
mais de toute manière rien et rien ne se
perd rien ne se crée il faut que cette
énergie soit rémunéré
à partir de là
l'hydraulique est effectivement un
élément extrêmement précieux le parc
nucléaire existant est un atout
compétitif absolument majeur le nouveau
nucléaire coûtera plus cher que le parc
existant
il faudra faire en sorte d'améliorer son
coût pour qu'ils deviennent compétitifs
on peut imaginer qu'on soit capable à
terme de produire du lait trop nucléaire
autour du prix du thermique c'est à dire
autour de
75 euros le mégawattheure
on est capable de le faire mais je ne le
dit pas officiellement
et puis
et puis les énergies nouvelles on
gagnera un peu de compétitivité mais de
façon marginale par rapport à ce que
j'évoquais
plus locaux de l'intermittence qui
représente 30% du coût du gâchis à peu
près rajouter aux coûts directs
c'est-à-dire quand coûts complets on ne
vas prendre 30 % de plus pour le coût
des énergies dites nouvelles par rapport
aux énergies qui centralise et puis s'y
ajoutent les énergies réparties c'est à
dire toutes les ressources locales si on
termine biomasse
les énergies
locales qui peuvent être le white son
énergie par exemple la transformation
des déchets en énergie au travers de
l'incinération et toutes les énergies et
notamment mais qui dépendent à la fois
de la sociologie la démographie la
tampographie etc et qui sentent à
regarder à la maille régional ou local
plus qu'à la marine nationale
voilà le sujet alors à partir de là
si on considère que l'ambition c'est
d'abord de donner
à l'électricité la place qui lui permet
de maintenir la compétitivité du
territoire et si on considère que dans
l'électrique dans l'électricité dans la
production électrique nucléaire doit
être à l'intérieur d'un méchoui soit
moins dominant aujourd'hui avec par
exemple un objectif à 50 % alors on peut
décliner et dire que 50% de
l'électronucléaire il 10% d'hydraulique
ce qui est à peu près cohérent avec les
hypothèses que j'ai retenu tout à
l'heure de croissance économique et de
croissance démographique puisque les 12
et demi vont devenir 10 dans les mêmes
hypothèses eh bien ça laisse 40%
d'énergie
à produire qui sauront qu'ils sont
aujourd'hui
nécessite il est nécessaire d'envisager
là dessus des nations toute leur place
encore une fois dans le souci de
maintenir la compétitivité des
territoires et la compétitivité que
ouais ce qu'on peut dire en quelques
mots vous m'avez monsieur président
poser la question sur l'hydraulique
pour préciser ma pensée monsieur le
président je pense tout simplement à la
compagnie nationale du rhône et pourquoi
ne pas trouver une solution du même type
particulier avec les collectivités dans
le cadre de la loi que nous avons voté à
l'unanimité la loi ces mots
c'est à dire une sem opération unique
concernant un appel d'offres qui
pourrait être
ouvert par rapport au renouvellement des
concessions c'est exactement ça que
j'avais en tête lorsque je vous ai
évoqué cette cette possibilité
l'hydraulique comme vous le savez
en france l'hydraulique et ce sont des
concessions de l'état lève et en edf et
ses concurrents et opérateurs pour le
compte de la nation de l'état
des des barrages qu'ils soient
d'ailleurs
des barrages de montagne où les barrages
sur sur l'euro
les concessions arrivent peu à peu avec
la question et quid du renouvellement de
ces concessions ou quid de la mise en
appel bol de ces concessions c'est tout
ce que que bruxelles souhaite que la
concurrence exerce et que les
laisser ces barrages soient mis en appel
d'offres
ce sujet est un sujet largement débattue
connu aujourd'hui je disais tout à
l'heure que le coût pour le pays ou ce
qu europe le poids économique
de l'hydraulique en france ne se limite
pas à la production d'énergie électrique
produite par ces barrages puisque
l'essentiel du poids économique est liée
à l'optimisation du système électrique
que ces barrages permettent de réaliser
au travers du stockage désir au fond ces
barrages furent beaucoup plus à stocker
l'énergie de manière à assumer avec
efficacité les arrêts des grandes
centrales et la maintenance des grands
sites de production que par la
production elle-même de la même manière
qu'elles permettent d'éponger les
pointes c'est donc une utilisation
beaucoup plus rationnelle que la simple
fabrication d'énergie d'électricité
courante par les barrages
dans ce contexte
bien que ne craignant pas la concurrence
df tout à fait capable de remporter les
appels d'offres je pense que de
l'optimisation du système électrique
permis par les barrages
est un élément majeur de l'excellence du
système électrique français par
conséquent nous nous sommes nous
déterminer afin de solliciter
l'attention de nos interlocuteurs pour
que
associé à un
programme important d'investissement les
concessions certaines des grandes
concessions puisse être prolongé en
contrepartie des travaux
d'investissement des investissements
nécessaires
qu'il est important d'y réaliser et que
nous puissions
en font
bénéficier d'une extension de la durée
des concessions au moins pour une partie
importante des barrages de manière à
maintenir l'efficacité du système
électrique français
ce débat est en cours
sam et ils sont possibles appels
d'offres tout court ou toute autre forme
de partenariat public privé qui ont été
évoqués qui sont toujours possibles
la dimension
régionale et locale est importante la
dimension nationale d'être aussi du fait
comme je le disais de l'outil défaite
d'efficacité du système que représentent
les barrages
mesdames et messieurs quelques grandes
réponses à leur mémère vous et en vos
dispositions pour les questions des
réponses plus précises aux questions
vous souhaitez j'ai passé la parole pour
quelques petites questions non pas par
des l engrais pas monsieur le noir
monsieur président avant de ne sait
aborder la question qui nous réunit je
voudrais vous demander que la commission
puisse se tenir une réunion sur alstom
des décisions importantes ont été prises
je crois que la commission des affaires
économiques ne peut pas se tenir à
l'écart
des informations qui sont diffusées ici
et là et donc je vous suggère au nom du
groupe ump que nous puissions avoir sans
tarder une réunion au préalable avec le
ministre en charge de ce dossier c'est à
dire monsieur arnaud montebourg
c'est le noir je vais vous répondre tout
de suite et cette question je suis très
favorable d'autant plus que j'ai eu un
contact bien en amont avec general
electric france et que je connaissais un
peu les donnes dossier
vous savez très bien que nous avons
auditionné monsieur le ministre de bourg
et que j'avais déjà essayé d'avoir une
réponse musclée prenait très bien que ya
un silence radio concernant les
négociations en cours même chose
d'ailleurs m'a été répondu lors de
l'audition de general electric france
comprenez bien que les personnes
n'avaient pas dévoilé de part et d'autre
leurs atouts en tous les cas si vous
voulez mon sentiment je considère que
c'est la meilleure des solutions parmi
les deux solutions envisagées je le dis
posément après avoir écouté pas après
avoir regardé sur l'ensemble la
complémentarité les centres de décision
concernant
indépendance aussi énergétique etc je
crois que moi je vous donne mon avis
personnel qui n'engage que moi que c'est
la meilleure des solutions qui a été
trouvé concernant votre proposition sur
le noir j'y adhère fortement maintenant
pourra trouver un créneau avec monsieur
montebourg
avant la fin des scissions
pas de gagner mais j'ai je regarde ma
dame de la bretèche et vous avez une
mission de contacter monsieur montebourg
j'imaginais bien que cette question
allait nous arriver
nous avons un calendrier législatif
relativement léger monsieur le noir pour
ce qui nous concerne notre commission je
parle pas l'accueil sur le développement
durable qui n'a rien à faire mais nous
nous avons un
programme allégé par rapport au régime
que nous avons connu depuis le début de
l'année ça nous fait d'ailleurs tout
drôle et donc j'adhère complètement à
votre idée de d'auditionner dorénavant
ou le ministre ou general electric
comme vous le souhaitez monsieur le noir
le président très clairement d'abord
monsieur montebourg
pour répondre à vos observations je
trouve que l'architecturé bonne gelé
toujours préconisé en revanche je
m'inquiète du contenu de ce qui a été
décidé car il ya de fortes incertitudes
par rapport à la prise de contrôle par
l'état sur le prix qui sera finalement
conclu donc vous parler des relations
entre brigue et l'état c'est à nous à
notre débat on y reviendra non mais ça
fait partie des crimes sur une aura
livré 29 cieux monsieur le président je
vais revenir maintenant au sujet qui
nous qui nous réunit merci monsieur le
président d'edf avoir apporté des
précisions vous l'avez compris nous
avons déjà entamé même si le texte n'est
pas avoir connu un dur
la loi de transition énergétique
quand je dis le texte n'est pas connu le
premier de loi fera porter par le
conseil des ministres dans quelques dans
quelques jours dans quelques semaines et
nous avons eu déjà des débats à dire du
sénat en commission d'abord l'initiative
du président de la commission mais
également en science publique avec
madame ségolène royal donc un certain
nombre de chiffres ont été avancés un
certain nombre d'observations été faite
alors je reprends les quelques points
que vous avez développé pour assister
sur des réponses que vous nous avez
apporté que vous pourrez précisé
il ya un point important c'est de savoir
quelle est la quantité d'électricité
dont nous aurons besoin d'ici à 2030
2040 c'est un grand débat quand je dis
c'est un grand débat
je lis un certain nombre de documents
qu'ils sont fournis par des gens qui
réfléchissent et je crois qu'on n'est
pas en contradiction avec les écrits
auxquelles j'aimerais faire la demande
en électricité va augmenter nous avons
aujourd'hui un gouvernement qui par sa
représentante en charge de l'écologie
l'énergie nous dit non vous vous trompez
la demande va baisser car nous allons
tout faire pour que on consomme moins
d'électricité
c'est un point majeur qu'à partir de là
ce sont les moyens de production dont
nous avons besoin qu'ils doivent être
identifiés et j'ai bien perçu
que vous avez dit à savoir compte tenu
de l'évolution démographique qui est un
facteur important et souvent méconnus
mais compte tenu aussi de la croissance
espérée nous avons besoin de maintenir
tous les réacteurs nucléaires
actuellement existants en fonction sans
compter les besoins que nous pouvons
avoir par ailleurs alors j'ai bien noté
vous avez dit après
s'agissant du mix mais après tout 50% de
nucléaire 10% d'hydraulique 40% donc on
pourra le problème je comprends que vous
ne puissiez pas l'exprimer ainsi
monsieur le président c'est que le
renouvelable a besoin de s'appuyer sur
du thermique classique du thermique à
flamme pour compenser aujourd'hui en
allemagne on a fortement développer
l'éolien photovoltaïque mais pour
compenser lorsqu'il ya pas de vent alors
qu'il passe au lait qu'est ce qu'on fait
on est en route des centrales charbon la
part du charbon est en train d'augmenter
or nous sommes en charge dans le cas de
la transition énergétique pas seulement
delà du besoin en énergie mais également
de la protection du climat donc ce point
doit être important
deuxièmement je le dis
sommes ici dans une assemblée où on peut
exprimer son opinion
pour un certain nombre de personnes le
débat sur la transition énergétique
c'est tout simplement la mort du
nucléaire c'est l'arrêt du nucléaire
alors je sais que au gouvernement on
n'en est pas là on ne le dit pas et même
je le dis comme je le pense la
communication qu'a fait madame ségolène
royal a dû certainement surprendre voire
des war des éléments écologistes qui
appartiennent à notre assemblée
effectivement on n'a pas vu des
échéances annoncées concernant la
fermeture de centrales nucléaires on est
loin des engagements qui ont été pris de
fermer 24 réacteurs d'ici à 2025 et on
ne parle pas de fait c'est dingue c'est
un point important car nous allons
certainement avoir besoin de cette
électricité alors maintenant le coup
monsieur le président vous le savez il
ya eu une commission denquête ici au
sénat il y en a une à l'assemblée
nationale plus récentes sur le coût du
nucléaire
une chose est sûre c'est que quels que
soient les chiffres divergent auquel
nous nous référons les uns les autres
l'électricité en france est de loin la
moins chère mis à part les pays du nord
que vous l'avez souligné et c'est un
point important
on dit - 40 % par rapport à nos voisins
c'est c'est la moitié par rapport aux
allemands pour
les usagers au temps au temps autant le
autant le rappelait alors sur
l'hydraulique ne peut croire que je la
fais régulièrement pour réveiller un peu
la mémoire pour éviter de tenir des
propos imprudents
la compagnie nationale du rhône était co
gérée par les collectivités edf je me
permets de rappeler une loi de décembre
je me rappelle qu'il gouvernait la
france à l'époque c'est la loi murcef
qui a fait que le capital a été ouvert
et que c'est un concurrent d'edf en
l'occurrence swayze du plus tard gdf
suez qui a repris la compagnie nationale
du rhône dernier point monsieur le
président qui est important c'est le
prix on a parlé du coup savoir quel est
le prix qu'on paye
alors je vous rappelle tout le monde le
sait mais il ya les tarifs il ya les
prix du marché pour les prix du marché
on n'en parle pas c'est le marché gris
et fixe les tarifs c'est le gouvernement
sur avis de la commission de régulation
de l'énergie il ya débat qu'on ne peut
pas occulter ici madame ségolène royal
annoncé que l'augmentation prévue serait
différent et que de toute façon ne
ferait pas du montant qui avait été
annoncé alors
je le dis tout de suite
pour éviter toute mauvaise
interprétation que jean
très tôt
vous êtes il y en a qui font ça quelles
sont leurs considérations dans cadre de
ce grand ensemble en point enfin autre
point que j'étais rapporteurs du paquet
énergie 3 x 20 en dehors de ce qu'a dit
jean claude que je partage moi je jeu
mega accent sur 1 20 d'efficacité
énergétique agathe ayew vous êtes avec
qui contactent que vous avez sur
l'ensemble des consommateurs
d'électricité en france qu'elle offre de
services avez-vous en réserve et
qu'allez-vous faire demain pour que
l'efficacité énergétique soit vraiment
au niveau nous souhaitons
si monsieur bourquin
oui quelques questions je remercie
monsieur le président directeur général
pour votre
exposé qui situe bien les enjeux
cependant je voudrais vous poser une ou
deux questions
la première quand on parle de transition
parle de dépendance à une seule source
d'énergie
et on aborde la possibilité d'avoir
plusieurs sources d'énergie et de
diversifier ses faux ces sources
d'énergie et il ne serait calamiteux
d'avoir le débat sur la transition pour
ou contre le nucléaire
serait vraiment dommageable
la question c'est aborder toutes les
questions telles que vous l'avez fait
dans votre exposé l'approvisionnement en
énergie qui est fondamental pour une
société on parle de compétitivité on
parle d'indépendance sont des questions
vitales aujourd'hui avec l'indépendance
alimentaire
après il ya les questions de politique
d'économie d'énergie
ça s'est posé avec une force inédite et
ensuite
l'avant ce que nous avons et que vous
avez bien fait remarquer comme grands
groupes
concernant la maîtrise du nucléaire et
la production d'électricité
comment vous la mettez à profit pour
justement prendre de l'avancé et ne pas
laisser cette avance simplement aux
allemands concernant les énergies
alternatives
non stockables dans vous parliez et dont
le problème et le stockage justement je
pense le vent l'eau et bien d'autres
sources d'énergie là on a on sait très
bien mais je crois que vous êtes mieux
placé que nous pour le savoir que
l'innovation dans la production
énergétique va prendre une dimension
tout à fait inédite et exceptionnelle
je rencontrais une start up il y a de
cela quelques mois qui me disait que il
avait produire du carburant avec des
algues et que ce carburant
pouvait être infinie
et surtout non producteurs de co2
alors bien sûr il ventait y vantait
c'est ce sa start up et son produit mais
on sait qu'ici et là en israël dans
beaucoup d'endroits il y à des
chercheurs qui mettent au point
des systèmes comment edf avec la
puissance de feu cayla excusez moi ce
n'est peut-être pas la bonne métaphore
mais avec la puissance qu'est la prépare
l'avenir pour que on sait très bien que
il y a eu et il y a aujourd'hui une
suprématie du nucléaire qui sera un
champ qui sera un jour remplacer par une
autre suprématie concernant la
production d'électricité voilà je finis
je le
directeur sur un sujet qui me tient à
coeur vous avez parlé d'un sujet
concernant l'hydraulique et les barrages
j'en ai un dans ma région
et
il a un gros problème c'est qu'il est
régulièrement le château dans le doubs
mais à la franco-suisse
il est régulièrement en travaux et quand
il est en travaux et bien c'est un
carnage piscicole
et comment fait-on pour éviter comme
vous le disiez tout à l'heure quand
l'hydro l'isthme vient prendre le relais
du nucléaire
comment on fait pour éviter les lâchers
de fond qui sont catastrophiques pour
les rivières
et comment on fait par exemple la dréal
par exemple de franche comté a proposé
de créer un by pass au niveau de la
centrale afin d'éviter que la rive
gauche par exemple qui est régulièrement
en travaux ne soient exempts d en cas de
rupture ça ce sont des une question que
vous pose à côté mais qui n'est pas une
petite question parce que six à chaque
barrage et si on revient
sur et j'ai bien écouté monsieur proglio
il a raison de dire que l'hydrolyse doit
être développée l'hydraulique oui
l'hydraulique doit être développée et
que dans l'hydraulique il y a les
concessions et si elle vient
systématiquement pour combler les
questions de 2,2 de commandes de perdre
d'électricité de puissance d'électricité
faisons en sorte que ça se fasse en
respectant l'environnement
merci monsieur sido
il vient merci monsieur le président où
j'ai bien écouté l'exposé de monsieur
proglio président d'edf et je le
remercie c'est très clair
il s'agit il s'agirait que le débat soit
elle est donnée soit très clair au
moment où on discutera de la loi sur la
transition énergétique et en particulier
tout tourne au delà des volontés
politiques louable c'est un rat tout
tourne autour du prix ou des coûts voilà
qui font la différence entre les deux
vont très bien les subtilités qui
m'échappe enfin bref des prix et vous
avez donné les prix monsieur le
président je vous en remercie
l'hydro électrique c'est le plus bas
tout est amorti un jour falloir faire
les barrages en tenant compte du prix du
kilo de poisson effectivement
le thermique vous l'avez dit c'est une
valeur aujourd'hui demain on ne sait par
les énergies nouvelles vous avez bien
dit effectivement où on en était sans
compter l'intermittence c'est à dire
qu'il faut une puissance équivalente
installée au pied du mât de l'éolienne
que ce qui est installé en haut
je trouve que 30 30% de plus vous êtes
très modeste on n'avait pas forcé le
trait et je vous en remercie ça permet
d'éclairer le débat ceci étant dit j'ai
je termine par le nucléaire je me
souviens qu'on a discuté d'une loi il ya
pas si longtemps vous battiez pour
convaincre que vous vendiez le
mégawattheure 42 euros c'est bien c'est
bon on en est à 55 et moi je vous pose
la question mais non monsieur je discute
pas moi je suis pas spécialiste de la
question je sais pas comment donc un
mais je vous pose la question d'où vient
cette dérive c'est là où je voulais en
venir n'en attendez attendez je
m'explique tandis que présidera je
m'explique
d'où vient cette dérive du prix du
kilowattheure et où est-ce que ça va
s'arrêter parce qu'au fond toute la
question est là
on ne sait pas au fond combien
véritablement quel est le prix du
mégawattheure ou de kilowattheures que
vous voudrez du nucléaire parce que tout
simplement pourquoi parce que déjà les
normes de démantèlement des futurs
démantèlement des centrales on en
rajoute tous les jours alors forcément
ça se
attaché au prix du kilowattheure demain
puisque on en rajoute tous les jours les
bétons qui n'ont absolument aucun
becquerel à distribuer mais il faudra
les mettre à mort vie et dans l'aube et
donc faire traverser la france des
millions de tonnes de déchets pour
aucune raison justifiant à bhl précise
faudrait peut-être aborder le débat
d'ailleurs
et puis je voudrais aborder quelque
chose qui me tient très à coeur c'est le
coût naturellement du projet cigéo tant
qu' on ne connaît pas le coût du projet
6 géo en toute bonne foi monsieur le
président
vous êtes bien incapable je ne comprends
bien d'ailleurs d'affiché à prix du
kilowattheure
et plus les années passent plus le
projet cigéo augmentant coup et ça ne
provient pas d augmentation des
subventions aux territoires non sas
apprend bien ça provient bien de je ne
sais pas pourquoi d'ailleurs exactement
et où est-ce que ça va s'arrêter puis en
plus ce demain on nous demande encore un
moratoire de deux ans pour réfléchir et
c'est un accident bien entendu l'andra
je veux pas reprendre le mot du général
de gaulle mais l'endroit est
forcément ravi de chercher deux ans de
plus enfin le coût de l'andra
sans rien faire c'est 200 millions
d'euros c'est combien ça coûte combien
l'andra par an par an rien que de faire
tourner quand est-ce que ça va s'arrêter
monsieur le président à votre avis
alors qu'on n'a plus les moyens en
france de payer toutes ces dérives et
par conséquent je j'aimerais bien avoir
votre sentiment
sur cette base on n'avance pas au niveau
de l'andra de la loi qui aurait dû être
attaché dans un titre supplémentaire sur
la transition énergétique seuil en
apprend j'ai appris ça hier à bure
d'ailleurs que finalement ça serait plus
dans la transition des reçus mais dans
une autre loi
demain
bourg etc
alors ce que je voulais vous dire
monsieur le président pour terminer
c'est que en tant que président de
l'office parlementaire je vais organiser
au mois de septembre une audition qui me
semblent importantes
importante parce que sans que je ne
demande rien du tout plusieurs
intervenants de des opérateurs
d'électricité en allemagne ont demandé à
me voir
je les ai donc reçu puisque je reçois
tout le monde
et ils m'ont dit écoutez vous la france
vous déjà l'office parlementaire c'est
très important nous on n'a pas
l'équivalent en francs en allemagne etc
nous sommes très intéressant
beaucoup d'acteurs beaucoup de membres
de cet office éminents
ont des idées sur la question et vous
avez commis plusieurs rapports
importants et remarquée sur cette
question et donc on vient vous voir pour
que nous les allemands vous aime bien
les français et oui enfin nous les
allemands producteur d'électricité
j'entends on vous aime bien et on
voudrait pas que vous fassiez les mêmes
erreurs que les nôtres
n'ont pas dit que nous ne sont pas les
producteurs d'électricité allemands qui
ont commis des horreurs sangala merkel
qui en huit jours a changé d'avis qui a
pris peur après fukushima et qui a
décidé et c'est bon et donc je vais
avoir une audition de des producteurs
certains de producteur d'électricité
allemand mais naturellement nous sommes
à l'office audition complètement ouverte
et contradictoires naturellement donc
vous serez invités monsieur proglio
de même que d'autres en france et puis
monsieur beaupain naturellement sera
invitée bien entendu et tout ce tous les
contempteurs et tous ceux qui sont
contre et que c'était enfin bref pour
qu'on ait un vrai débat et que l'office
parlementaire puisse en amont de la
discussion sur la transition énergétique
produira un rapport sur ce qui s'est dit
dans la journée dans une table ronde qui
sera public bien entendu avec
journalistes et caméras etc
voilà ce que je voulais vous dire mais
le cul le coeur du sujet c'est le prix
du kilowattheure me semble-t-il
merci j'avais pas que monsieur beaupain
été producteur d'électricité mais
les cons monsieur
thierry repentin juste non non je suis
pas sûr que le prix soit le seul facteur
de décision enfin pour nous de regarder
les champs selon monsieur tir et reporte
à plus de plus un art original je n'ai
qu'une question sur un sujet qui devrait
être aussi traité dans la loi sur la
transition que sont les mesures qui
pourraient être prises pour favoriser la
pérennité sur le sol français de grandes
entreprises qui sont aussi des clients
d'edf que sont les électro intensives il
se trouve qu'il y a un an vous êtes
rentré au capital d'une société avec un
partenaire allemand pour maintenir sur
le sol national deux entités une dans
les pyrénées une dans les alpes
permettant moi je dois le dire de
trouver une solution qui a maintenu 600
emplois directs 2000 sous traitants et
qui 11 mois après embauche de nouveaux
sur les deux sites que ce soit dans les
pyrénées les alpes bon cet accord n'est
pas allée de soi au début c'était
difficile mais je voudrais savoir avec
le recul monsieur le président directeur
général ce que vous retirez de cette
expérience et si nous pouvons imaginer
que edf puisse renouveler
ce type d'accord qui a été validée
d'ailleurs par les autorités
bruxelloises sinon nous aurions dû
effectivement il y renoncer car je crois
qu'il s'agit là aussi de effectivement à
la solidité de l'économie française mais
aussi la balance de l'exportation vous y
êtes attachés comme grands industriels
comme fervent défenseur de l'équipe
france et donc je voudrais savoir si
effectivement vous êtes de nouveau
ouvert à ce type de solutions
oui mais je comprends très bien la
question de tirer avantage c'est pas sûr
que est pas une évolution la part de la
commission de bruxelles sur cet accord
j'ai cru comprendre que il avait donné
oui le feu vert mais suis pas sûr
qu'elle renouvelle monsieur visait
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
président proglio vous avez parlé tout à
l'heure en début de propos des
différents coûts de l'énergie et je vous
en remercie et vous avez souligné
l' irruption dans le paysage énergétique
mondial
de nos amis américains qui avec le gaz
de schiste ont totalement modifié le
coût de l'énergie et si hier nous avons
malheureusement pu constater des
délocalisations
lui au coût horaire du travail
délocalisation de l'europe vers l'asie
je crains que nous ayons demain même
très rapidement des délocalisations que
j'appellerais énergétique mais n'ont pas
de l'europe vers l'asie mais de l'europe
vers les états unis à cause précisément
du coût de l'énergie je vous donne
simplement un chiffre et depuis les deux
dernières années un certain nombre du
comme on dirait l'entreprise électro
intensives allemandes ont investi près
de 12 milliards d'euros à l'étranger
dont 10 milliards précisément sous
tendue par le fait de la recherche d'une
énergie moins en moins cher qu'en
allemagne donc
moi ma question la question que je
voulais vous poser concerne l'europe de
l'énergie je crois que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans un contexte on parle
beaucoup de transition énergétique on
s'aperçoit en regardant ce que fait
l'allemagne que c'est surtout pas
l'exemple qu'il faut qu'il faut suivre
et que la transition énergétique ne peut
se raisonner à titre individuel étape
par étape ce ne peut être qu'une
approche je dirais d'ensemble donc moi
j'appelle de mes voeux déjà depuis
quelque temps une coopération renforcée
en la matière
je vais saluer avec intérêt la création
du groupe magritte par monsieur
mestrallet gdf suez la question est donc
la suivante
comment un grand groupe tel que quelques
nouveautés peut-il
pertinemment intéresser les pouvoirs
publics pour essayer de faire comprendre
que là la création d'une europe de
l'énergie est aujourd'hui une urgente
nécessité vous allez me dire c'est une
décision politique
uniquement politique certes je le
conçois sauf que s'il y a des pressions
d'un certain nombre de grandes
entreprises la décision elle sera plus
il sera prise plus aisément et plus
rapidement et pour moi mon avis si on
veut rien du sste réalisé l'europe si on
veut rien esprits et l'affreux
industrialisés la france l'urgence de la
création d'une europe de l'énergie est
plus que jamais d'actualité
merci monsieur le président la parole
est à la défense merci monsieur que je
me sens pas tellement à gré c'est
d'ailleurs dans les propos mais je vais
essayer de répondre puis si j'oublie tel
ou tel sujet nous je vous prie de
m'excuser je suis tout à fait disposé à
revenir en arrière ou en tout cas à
compléter tout d'abord je voudrais
revenir sur les fondamentaux essayé au
fond edf n'est pas un producteur
d'énergie électrique
edf d'un opérateur service public c'est
un peu différent si je puis me permettre
c'est assez différent pourquoi parce que
nous avons une mission thérèse public il
cette mission de service public elle
consiste à donner au territoire national
et à ses concitoyens à la fois l'énergie
en quantité enduré en pérennité de
services en compétitivité suffisante
pour assurer cette mission
ceci étant posé
ça veut dire qu edf n'est en rien
hostile aux économies d'énergie alors
regarde parfois de manière un peu étonné
mais comment qu'est ce que vous allez
faire pourquoi est ce que vous vous
battez pour faire des économies
d'énergie alors que vous êtes vendeur
d'électricité les deuxièmement edf n'est
pas le lobby nucléaire d'ailleurs quand
on regarde edf globalement
dans le monde entier en dehors de la
france et la grande-bretagne ailleurs on
n'est pas nucléaire donc on est on est
en fonction des pays plus ou moins
orienté vers l'optimisation et
l'existant
donc on sait date est vrai par la
reporte repousser un peu l'idée que ont
défendu clair parce qu'au fond c'est
notre spécialité notre notre expertise
nous on a plusieurs expertises on est
les premiers développeurs d'énergies
nouvelles en europe effectivement nous
sommes les premiers opérateurs
nucléaires au monde encore une fois les
premiers d'hydraulicien alors en europe
au monde non puisque les ressources
hydrauliques du canada de la russie du
brésil
sont telles que vivant on n'est pas
compétitif 1 on est en volume et de la
chine maintenant avec les trois gorges
font que aujourd'hui on est le cinquième
opérateur mondial derrière ces mammouths
mais ces mammouths qui sont là parce que
les raisons géographiques et géologiques
sont tels qu'on peut pas être compétitif
sauf si et c'est ce qu'on travaille on
se développe partout dans le monde dans
le d'hydraulique de manière en fait on
peut pas se limiter à la france d'une
façon l'edf est trop gros aujourd'hui
pour être exclusivement français nous
avons une mission de service public en
france dont de la fierté de la sub et de
la suivre de manière efficace et de
répondre à toutes les questions et c'est
la question de la transition énergétique
en france est une question qui se pose à
nous avec elle on essaie de donner
meilleure réponse possible mais sans
qu'il y ait un sous jacent je dirais d'à
priori industriels non on essaie de
faire en sorte que la mission de service
public soient remboursées soit soit soit
je dirais le mot d'ordre est le fil
conducteur de notre démarche même en
ville et pas si je le rappelle mais
c'est important je crois de 2,2
systématiquement leurs maîtres en point
d'orgue parce que sinon on apparaîtra
comédiens toujours de parti pris mais
c'est pas le sujet donc si jamais le
sentiment qu'au fond il faille
véritablement baisser la puissance
nucléaire de la france parce que c'est
l'intérêt de la france je le ferai quand
année mon sens comble de vaud donc donc
ne voyez pas le moindre coût' dans le
raisonnement
deuxièmement la loi nome bon alors en
france là les politiques en selle des
gouvernements successifs ont décidé à la
fois d'assurer l'indépendance
énergétique la prévisibilité la
compétitivité des territoires qui ont
été à l'origine de l'aventuré nucléaire
française qui a été confiée à edf
qui a rendu sa copie aujourd'hui on peut
le reconnaître avec un certain succès
mais par ailleurs comme les pouvoirs
publics ont décidé ne pas casser l'outil
nucléaire pour ne pourrons préserver à
la fois la sûreté du clair d'une part la
compétitivité la compétence de l'autre
et éviter le désordre corps a provoqué
la scission en plusieurs morceaux du
parc nucléaire est bien du fait de la
compétitivité de ce parc nucléaire on
nous forcer à accepter une loi qui nous
fasse subventionner la concurrence de
dire qu'au fond la loi nome qu'est ce
que c'est on vend notre capacité électro
nucléaire 25% de la production
électronucléaire française à nos
concurrents à un prix significativement
inférieur à son coût de revient je vous
ai dit que son coût de revient était à
55 euros je le maintiens nous l'avions
dit à l'époque certains de nos
concurrents prétendez que c'était 31
euros bullshit total enfin aujourd'hui
on le sait qu'ils mentaient non on n'en
tire pas les conséquences nécessaires
ils ont menti je dis simplement que on a
accepté 42 euros parce que c'était le
niveau du tartam l'époque passer en
famille plus personne ne connaît la
famille l'oncle ne papa la maman tartare
fabrice était 42,0 le tartam de l'été il
y avait un partant de l'été un tartam
divers entité enfin fallait 10 pers
spécialiste pardon jean-claude mais ça
existe et on a dit bon allez 42 bon tu
battu comme un chien pour avoir 42 euros
on a eu 42 euros qui était bien sûr
inférieur au coût qu'aux économies donc
on peut pas nous reprocher aujourd'hui
que le coût économique soit supérieur
j'ai simplement répondre à la question
est ce que le prix des dérivés non
c'était déjà 55 sont 20 à 40
non mais
je voudrais simplement soulager les
scrupules moraux de monsieur silo on n'a
pas dérapé c'est simplement que c'était
déjà le cas les
pardons
ah oui non c'est stupide non c'est pas
le prix est le 42 c'était un convention
cédées au prix prix de cession favorable
c'est-à-dire qu'on subventionner la
concurrence pour qu'elle puisse venir
nous piquer des parts de marché c'est
assez original mais on est les seuls
industriels au monde qui on demande de
financer les concurrents pour qu'ils
viennent de vous piquer des parts de
marché vous êtes et l'egypte c'est hier
donc donc c'est bien mais
dans la mission de service public il ya
aussi le fait de subventionner les
concurrents c'est comme ça
donc oui aux services énergétiques
oui à l'optimisation énergétique sous
quelle forme alors c'est vrai que la
maison edf n'y était pas nécessairement
préalablement accoutumée parce que
c'était pas son métier d'origine
d'autant plus que jusqu'en 2006 date
d'ouverture du marché edf avait
l'interdiction
l'interdiction par le principe de
spécialité de développer des services
énergétiques
d'où l'initiative qui avait été prise
pour mon art et prédécesseur françois
roussely avec ma petite personne à
l'origine de l'accord dalkia qui préside
au destin de cette entreprise de veolia
lorsque nous avons croisé le destin avec
edf pour créer cette plateforme de
services énergétiques commune entre
dalkia veolia que nous allons récupérer
janyk qui était qui et révocation être
le complément d'objet direct de services
énergétiques dr prix national d'éthique
à l'opérateur historique aujourd'hui on
va le récupérer et on va avoir une offre
un service à la fois dans l'optimisation
énergétique pour le logement le bâtiment
est l'entreprise en train dalkia et les
collectivités territoriales réseau de
chauffage refroidissement
en même temps pour l'industrie services
industriels optimisation de systèmes
d'énergie pour les entreprises en même
temps que l'éclairage public était due
en même temps que des services
énergétiques des réparties à la maille
locales avec notamment le waste aux
énergies
avec
avec tiru etc donc vous voyez on a un
bloc de services d'optimisation
énergétique qui va être deux mois à
partir du mois de juillet le complément
d'objet direct du réacteur d'élèves sur
sur la maille locale d'une part
l'optimisation énergétique d'autres
agents rajoute à ça que dans les débats
que nous avons eus en france sur les
sujets énergétiques
quand le sujet s'est posée de la fameuse
discussion sur la loi nome en
et ce combat homérique pour obtenir les
42 euros qui évidemment comme je te
rappeler à l'instar du vendredi me
répéter à l'époque 2012 pendant sortait
une réglementation thermique
pourquoi pas si ce n'est qu'on l'a
confié à gaz de france qui a rédigé le
texte de l'optimisation de la
réglementation thermique qui comme par
hasard la réglementation thermique
française est totalement pro gazière en
font aujourd'hui alors on peut pas se
battre sur tous les fronts je m'étais
battu sur le front de la loi nome je
pouvais pas en même temps pour éviter de
me faire curiace me battre sur le
problème de la grèce aujourd'hui je pose
la question il est très ouvert pourquoi
est ce que cette réglementation
thermique est autant en faveur du gaz
c'est à dire de la neige est importé et
pourquoi est ce qu'elle ne répond pas
aux attentes de l'optimisation en
matière de logement la question est
ouverte mais ces messieurs les
parlementaires et donc au fond moi je
lui dis qu'une réglementation peu suivie
d'une autre augmentation elle n'est pas
figée dans le nord on peut toujours
réfléchir j'incite à la réflexion car
j'ai le souci aujourd'hui de dans
l'optimisation du système énergétique
français au sens large que les économies
d'énergie l'optimisation énergétique du
logement ne passe pas forcément par les
importations gazières et que cette
réglementation mérite d'être au moins
régulier c'est tout ce que je veux dire
pardon mais
je me devais de le rappeler parce que
dès lors qu'on parle d'économie
d'énergie l'optimisation énergétique
qu'il faut voir toute la palette des
mesures alors les mesures incitatives
font partie de cette démarche
donc oui l'edf sera un acteur est un
acteur important de l'optimisation
énergétique économie énergie parce que
c'est censé sa mission mais j'allais
dire c'est son métier et nous le ferons
complètement ce qui ne veut pas dire
pour autant que en complément d'objet
direct nous repartions sur
comment est-ce qu'on peut optimiser le
système énergétique in usa
qui nous est comment dirais-je confié
c'est à dire une électricité et qu' une
partie d'aucune mise à sion viendra du
mix énergétique allemande de fabrication
une autre partie viendra en aval de 10
économies énergies la troisième partie
viendra au milieu des réseaux
intelligents qui font partie du système
électrique et donc les smart grids et
donc les réseaux intelligents qui seront
un des éléments clés de l'optimisation
énergétique et nous nous investissons
simultanément sur la main sur la balle
et sur les réseaux
jeux confèrent les 6 milliards que nous
allons investir pour le compteur dit
interactif qui sera un des premiers
éléments des réseaux intelligents pas le
seul et devant et puis tout ça parce
qu'on est un grand opérateur mondial
draine toute une industrie sous jacentes
oui nous sommes les leaders parce qu on
est l'opérateur de référence en matière
nucléaire et qu'il est légitime et
normal que nous assumions responsabilité
particulière dans la filière
industrielle du nucléaire français dans
le monde oui et nous le faisons de façon
délibérée
volontaire et responsable
parce que c'est quand je dédie une
certaine époque
critiqués y ces deux cent cinquante
mille emplois directs et industriels est
clair français c'est le troisième
filière industrielle française derrière
l'automobile et l'aéronautique
ne l'oublions pas ces emplois si on
gagne la bataille du nucléaire mondial
il ne demande qu'à se développer c'est
notre responsabilité collective en tout
cas c'est la nuit
ensuite vous avez toute la démarche
industrielle dans les autres systèmes
électriques dans les autres moyens de
production vous avez parlé des énergies
nouvelles nous sommes le premier
développeur d'énergie nouvelles au
monde- en europe au travers d'aidés f
hainard chine nouvelle dont nous
maîtrisons désormais 100% du capital et
bien nous développons ces énergies
nouvelles par tous et rationnelle parce
que la mission de service public fait
que plutôt que de rebondir sur les modes
ou sur les spéculations moment en 2011
2010 début 2010 où je visite
la campagne française des landes
dévastée par la tempête katrina je vois
le président du conseil jean lé jeudi
président trouve que nous connaissons
tous bientôt au département sera une
immense ferme photovoltaïque y aura plus
d'habitants parce qu'il aura plus des
spasmes simplement les 600 euros le
mégawattheure de subventions versées à
fait de tarifs garantis pour le
photovoltaïque dans les landes était
tellement élevé 600 euros que tous les
propriétaires terriens avait intérêt à
fabriquer des fermes photovoltaïques
plutôt qu'à faire repousser des pins
j'ai le le leurs revenus annuels
provoquent procurés par les fermes
photovoltaïques qui était deux fois
supérieur à la valeur de leur patrimoine
chaque année bon il ya une spéculation
folle quand on voit le désastre allemand
c'est la conséquence d'une spéculation
financière c'est ni plus ni moins que ça
quand je rencontre le ministre allemand
de l'énergie il ya maintenant un peu
plus de 12 mois qui était à l'époque
ministre de l'énergie il est maintenant
chanceux
ministre la chancellerie ces haltes maya
et bio et vous faire une confidence le
montant des subventions déjà accordé
renouvelables allemand dépasse les 1200
milliards d'euro
bonds
capitaliser sur les 20 ans de contrat
puisque ces sont des contrats à prix est
pure annuel comme chez nous ça veut dire
que c'était 20% de plus que la
réunification allemande on s'étonne
après du désastre
donc c'est vrai que l'allemagne est un
contre exemple aujourd'hui on peut le
dire les allemands eux mêmes
reconnaissent alors qu'ils avaient non
simplement il était malsain de dire
parce que c'était pas politiquement
correct de fait on est devant ce
désastre à la ce qui fait que les deux
opérateurs allemands sont aujourd'hui on
n'est pas un état avancé de
décomposition voire de dépôt de bilan
pour l'un des deux
constaté quand je vends notre filiale
allemande en 2011 bon qu'avant pour 7
milliards d'euros elle ne vaut plus rien
elle ne vaut plus rien
donc
parce qu'il était évident de tourner au
désastre c'était bien c'était avant les
événements
donc voilà la réalité donc la mission de
service public fait qu edf ne peut pas
se permettre d'être spéculateurs
financiers
ne peut pas se permettre de ne pas ne
pas anticiper ne peut pas se permettre
d'être simplement d'épouser les contours
des modes
mais se sent responsable sur la durée de
cette mission est de sa responsabilité
vis-à-vis de la france et des français
et de l'économie française une des
questions c est ce que nous acceptons
oui on n'acceptera de toute façon
d'accompagner l'économie française et
l'industrie française dans la limite du
raisonnable c'est à dire il ne s'agit
pas d'aller subventionné entre
guillemets des entreprises en difficulté
ce n'est pas le sujet mais s'il s'agit
de donner à l'entreprise france aux
entreprises installées en france quelle
que soit leur nationalité un atout
compétitif qui s'appelle électricité oui
en forme dès lors que c'est possible dès
lors qu'on aura les autorisations dès
lors qu'on sera pas condamné à bruxelles
pour être d'état donc il faut être assez
attentifs aux modalités opératoires on a
signé des contrats dans cette
perspective là on les avenante et de
manière à petit je ne veux pas trop mal
m'appesantir sur ces sujets parce qu'ils
nous rendent vulnérables aux attaques de
nos chers concurrents l'europe de
l'énergie n'existe pas on parle pas
d'une page blanche aujourd'hui la
compétition fait rage entre les pays
européens
on a
on a nous avons collectivement la france
a un atout dans ce domaine
alors la solidarité c'est pas forcément
de partager la toux avec ceux qui n'en
n'ont pas
parce que finalement on n'est pas assez
riche pour ça donc
l'égoïsme c'est à dire la compétitivité
du territoire parce que si on doit faire
la différence on la fera sur nos atouts
et pas sur nos faiblesses soyons
consciente de faiblesse essayant de les
contourner mais ce livre conscience il
nous a tout essayé de ne pas les
partager c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui tout
le monde nous jalousent notre
compétitivité dans le domaine électrique
de louise attaque nous sommes
systématique par l'objet c'est pas une
raison pour les pour les partager donc
je pense que
avant de passer de parler de l'europe de
l'énergie par la france de l'énergie et
parlant de les atouts français et puis
ensuite parlons des défauts des autres
et puis voyons comment éventuellement
nos atouts peuvent leur permettre à eux
d'avoir je dirais une réponse à leurs
questions mais sans pour autant négliger
notre compétitivité ni notre nos
quelques avantages encore une fois
qu'ils sont très importants pour
l'emploi pour la compétitivité de
thierry perret pour l'entreprise france
/
sur le coût de l'énergie encore une fois
on ne voit aucune
aucun atout dans les autres énergies que
dans l'électricité puisque les autres
énergies par définition sont d'apporter
enfin des énergies fossiles en tout cas
les énergies
nouvelles entre guillemets renouvelables
l'hydraulique bien entendu qu'est la
première d'entre elles et les autres
énergies renouvelables doivent être
sollicités pour autant qu'elles sont
rationnels c'est-à-dire qu'ils obéissent
c'est vrai qu'il vaut mieux faire du
photovoltaïque la une du soleil
malheureusement on a eu l'habitude pour
compenser des gens qui n'avaient pas la
chance d'avoir du soleil de leur donner
des prix des subventions plus
importantes que là où il ya du soleil
qui fait qu' on a beaucoup développer le
photovoltaïque en or et beaucoup moins
dans le sud pas forcément rationnelle
mais ça faisait partie 2 voilà dix
revendications naturellement des
territoires c'est normal que quelqu'un
qui n'a pas de soleil veuille se
compenser le manque de soleil par des
subventions mais le problème c'est que
ça marche pas dans l'énergie et c'est
comme ça que l'allemagne a développé
beaucoup photovoltaïque au nord de
l'allemagne hors cétacés rien parce que
quand on connaît le nord de l'allemagne
on sait qu'il n'est pas écrasé ne va pas
tous les jours en tout cas
et de la même manière on a fait des
photos d'eux du de l'eonia là où il n'y
avait pas de vent
on pourra bientôt et pour des raisons
écolo d'ailleurs on nous fera faire des
éoliennes dans les talwegs protéger du
vent parce qu'ils seront profondeur mais
c'est vrai que c'est pas totalement
rationnelle il vaut mieux le mettre sur
des crêtes
que dans des bas mais là aussi la
subvention fausse tout syfy de
contrebalancés par des subventions des
conditions économiques ou des conditions
géographiques défavorable alors c'est
vrai que ça conduit des conclusions on
peut en option
voilà ce que je voulais dire en quelque
sorte
les collectivités territoriales en
enrôlant absolument déterminant à jouer
dès lors que
on regarde le problème un des économies
d'énergie d'optimisation énergétique
parce que c'est vrai que par exemple
dans le dans le logement qui mieux que
les élus locaux connaissent le
patrimoine et
connaissent
l'efficacité des interventions qui
peuvent être réalisés donc au fond des
centres alizés rapprocher d'eux du
territoire tous les efforts
d'optimisation énergétique me paraît
vraisemblablement la meilleure solution
sans pour autant
faire en sorte qu' il est des connexions
entre la maille territoriale et la
marine nationale parce qu'il faut que ça
soit cohérent il faut que le système
soit cohérent c'est à dire que le
système réparti et le système centralisé
travaillent la main dans la main de
manière efficace et que chacun sache qui
fait quoi manière à ce qu'ils me
redondance ni rupture de raisonnement
je crois beaucoup au système intégré je
crois beaucoup l'efficacité du système
intégré je crois au fait que les réseaux
s'intègre parfaitement à l'amont et à
l'aval du cycle parce que dès lors
commencer par les réseaux de la
production et de la commercialisation et
d'optimisation énergétique on va vers
des incohérences on le voit dans le
faire de manière un peu caricaturale
on peut le faire aussi dans
l'électricité c'est assez facile de
répliquer ou de dupliquer des bêtises
mais lorsqu'on se rend compte qu'on les
a fait c'est pas la peine d'essayer de
d'un ajouter une à la une autre pour
pour démontrer qu'on est capable de
faire c'est déjà c'est déjà assez clair
voilà pour cette audition d'henri
proglio le pdg d'edf qui s'est exprimé
lors de cette audition sur les priorités
à mettre en oeuvre pour atteindre les
priorités gouvernement en matière de
réduction des gaz à effet de serre en
matière de réduction de la part du
nucléaire dans notre mix énergétique et
afin d'augmenter la part des énergies
renouvelables
vous pouvez toujours voir et revoir
toutes les auditions sur notre site sur
publicsenat.fr prochain rendez vous de
l'actualité parlementaire à 19h pour 24
heures sénat présenté par delphine
girard très bonne journée sur les
chaînes parlementaires